story The New York Times claims a lot of
the news that people relied on during
the election was actually just made up
stories peddled by fake news websites oh
really
yeah oh that's it I quit come on what's
wrong Eddie I can't take it I feel like
the world's gone crazy I'm sorry but I
need to take a trip to happy Stan
sorry Andi VAX happiest a nicer let's
see I thought that was just some trash
you were trying to get rid of no Conan
happy Stan is a safe place that I
created where I can escape from all the
negativity in the world and just be
alone for a moment with my joy I'll be
right back all right well well anything
happen well it is oh that's nice oh yeah
hey well Andy's in happy Stan I'll
finish this story according to the New
York Times and this is interesting
voters were manipulated by these fake
news sites and Andy Andy what are you
doing well I feel a lot better gonna
dance
good old happy Stan so Andy uh
everything okay
oh man I'm great let's do a show let's
do a show right now what are we doing
okay I was still talking about fake news
sites that influence the election yeah
yeah yeah blah blah blah my happiness is
wearing off sorry anyway oh yeah even
worse these fake news sites weren't even
politically motivated oh just to get
money and any guy here Andy Oh Merry
Christmas let's go Andy Andy what's
really going on in happy Stan please
just like a childlike sense of joy come
on now let's interview dr. Phil mother
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah any dr. Phil isn't even a guest
tonight as disappointing all right or
anyway oh sorry for not playing music
yeah
all right that's a good one boss I'll
see you guys later all right
dr. Phil here yet I want to talk to him
all right I already said Andy dr. Phil
is not here tonight I need to know
what's going on in happy Stan I need to
know right now
what's the big deal I mean all we're
doing is enjoying some powdered sugar
donuts okay so you were getting that
pumped up just from Donuts yeah I mean
how do you get your kicks weirdo
this sketch brought to you by El hippies
cocaine filled Donuts how did you get
your kicks from here doh
[Applause]
you
yeah
[Applause]
Oh
all right
[Applause]
my dream was to have a show like Charlie
Rose and this is what we have
you